when you talk about the progress that
you're making and the changes that
you're seeing happen does it worry you
that this kind of progress will be held
up or held into question as you look at
this political cycle when we have
candidates who are so outspoken or
negative in terms of foreign policy
countries like China when Donald Trump
is so negative does it concern you in
terms of the good progress you've made
well I won't weigh in on politics become
diplomatic enough to say very clear of
that but I will say that you know
certain aspects of foreign policy have
to have continuity there is no way to
deal with the threats of our time to
deal with ISIL to stop the financing
without actually building multilateral
coalition's and to build multilateral
coalition's you have to hear and listen
what other countries interests are you
have to be capable of building bridges
and I think President Obama has done a
forceful job of that we have a 65
country coalition against ISIL we have a
coalition to combat climate change we've
invested in UN peacekeeping which goes
to places that are have not yes sir yet
necessarily gone to full-fledged war
that implicates our direct national
interest in the way that that's
traditionally conceived but if we nip
things in the bud that might mean fewer
extremists in the long term so you got
to invest in the in the multilateral
institutions in the multilateral
framework you can't just show up and get
what you want when you want it another
subject we talk about every day in this
program is Europe there are a lot of
headwinds that Europe's facing right now
and some of them are coming from the
refugee the migrant situation and even
overnight there was talk about a
possible deal with Turkey and the EU you
have been very involved in this issue
where are we right now in terms of
refugees coming out of Syria in
particular but Middle East more
generally and what's the path forward
well first to say this is a global
phenomenon a global tragedy there's 60
million displaced people 20 million of
whom are refugees meaning they cross an
international border the world has never
been more generous private donors have
never been more generous governments and
yet the need is so outpacing the demand
one of the reasons we saw the spike in
the flow to Europe was that the World
Food Programme because of the size of
the appeal and again the inability to
fill it you despite the u.s. giving five
billion dollars on the to the Syria
humanitarian appeals over the life of
the war there but by virtue of the fact
that
were being cut schools were not being
set up because there just was barely
enough resources to feed people never
mind to take on the schooling that's
when people began to vote with their
feet and they began that they got text
messages saying your rations are going
to be cut in half if you're a parent
you're looking at your kids you're
thinking okay now make or break let me
entrust my family's life to the smuggler
that might be the best I can do it so
it's either barrel bombs from the Assad
regime ISIL in this area or a smuggler
it's it's talk about Sophie's choices so
I think what's important is that just as
the the phenomenon is a global
phenomenon so to the responsibility to
deal with it has to be spread more
equitably around the world and President
Obama actually in September at the
General Assembly when the heads of state
come back together is going to be
chairing a head of state summit to try
to actually spread the burden across
more countries there many countries in
the world who don't take refugees at all
they may be geographically far afield
from Syria but there's a way to actually
spread the burden the right now is
falling on the neighboring countries
first and foremost turkey Jordan Lebanon
principally but now of course into
Europe but the sonic state what you're
talking about is the symptom the
refugees are the symptom of a
fundamental underlying disease yes can
we really solve this without radical
regime change in syria itself well what
we what we can't solve it with in order
to solve it we have to have political
solutions and that's why secretary Kerry
is investing so much including in
collaboration with the Russian
Federation which has been on a very
different side of this conflict with a
better part of five years but we were we
are recognizing that the cut would that
one of the reasons the refugee flow is
what it is is that conflicts aren't
ending as quickly as they once did and
so Syria is a good example it's five
years and counting we've started to see
a reduction in the violence by virtue of
a cessation of hostilities that's
important there's less refugee flow when
there are fewer bombs falling from the
sky but a long term solution is going to
require something that's going to
convince the majority of Syrians to put
their guns down and convince Syrians
abroad when the time is right to
actually come home and that's going to
take a lot more work so realistically
how close are we to any sort of real
resolution to stop this i mean there's
meetings going on in Turkey right now
saying will there be a resolution is
that even a
possibility as we head into warmer
months we're only going to see more
refugees cross into countries like
Greece and Italy I think that's where
David's point is so important we've got
to get a political solution not just for
Syria we need out in Myanmar there's the
same issue of rahunga getting on boats
and risking their lives and interesting
smugglers and so forth again the rights
within a country dictate whether or not
people are willing to entrust the lives
of their families to frankly horrible
horrible people who are putting innocent
families on dinghies that barely float
and giving them life jackets that don't
function and so how close are we I mean
it really depends on what we can achieve
again on the political track in terms of
whether the flow will continue but I
think it's also important to note that
Turkey Jordan Lebanon you know their
financial investments we can make in
these areas the host communities that
have sheltered these refugees for more
than now going on five years i have
really born this burden without it being
spread around the world and so part of
what has to happen is we the World Bank
others need to invest more again and
those and those who shouldered a
disproportionate burden it strikes me
that we have the situation in Libya
where the the world the Western world
took a very different approach fairly
militarily active approach and the US
had a very significant orla and we end
up with a result that wasn't very good
what you've been a student at this for
some years what have we learned from the
experiences of Syria versus Libya about
what the best world response is well of
course not we can't be satisfied with
either outcome the situation in Libya is
very unstable although they're moving
haltingly toward a kind of government of
national Accord which couldn't come a
moment too soon because ISIL has laid
down a foothold there look in Libya
there was a great reluctance on the part
of the Libyans who had earned themselves
life without Qaddafi to want an
international presence of any kind on
the ground very proud very attendant to
their sovereignty and basically said
thank you for the help getting rid of
Gaddafi we got it from here and then
there were divisions that that toured
the society apart in Syria it's very
hard to argue i think when one looks
back at the five years no one can be
proud of the results because of the
heartbreak that
fence every day because of the rise of
terrorism but by the same token it's
hard to see this magic tool that had we
just done X or Y suddenly you know the
the demons that have been unleashed in
Syria would have gone back into the into
the box or into the bottle so it's these
are very complex societies we open the
tool tool box that we have we try to
deploy as many tools as we can to
mitigate suffering in order to get the
kinds of political solutions that will
bring conflicts to an end sooner but it
but it's challenging and we only have a
short time left as the Obama
administration we're going to work every
minute to try to put those conflicts in
a much better place before we leave
we're not going to talk politics but as
you watch all of this unfold foreign
policy is going to be extraordinarily
important and difficult for the next
president of the United States may be
more difficult than any president we
will see in our lifetime what is the
most important thing that needs to be
employed those first hundred days when
you look at this what do you think we
need the most well I think an investment
in diplomacy a lot there's a lot of talk
in the certain circles in the campaign
about military force military force
where would we use it what would we do
but truly building these coalition's is
what is required to bring about
political solutions and there's not one
of the conflicts on the global stage
that can be settled simply by the barrel
of the gun even the terrorism challenge
where we've invested of course in
combating that militarily in building
this coalition you've got to cut off
financing you've got to maintain border
security you've got to share information
about who's who in order to protect you
know your people and make sure the wrong
people don't come into your country then
are you surprised that diplomacy is I
feel like what we've heard the least of
in all of these debates on all of these
meetings what's not what is it I don't
know I'm a diplomatic nerd but it
doesn't make much of a soundbite it's
not like the bumper sticker don't go do
diplomacy you know go listen that's not
going to work necessarily in a campaign
but but one hopes that cooler heads will
prevail and you know there's there there
are a lot of career foreign policy
professionals who are also fuel our
foreign policy across administration's
regardless of who's in place so again we
hope that investing the kinds of
coalition's that you need understanding
that
military force can be a component of
dealing with violent people especially
but it but it has to be part of a
fulsome strategy I mean that's something
that because you can't succeed otherwise
ultimately people are going to come to
that conclusion self-described
diplomatic nerve right there you said
there's no there's no sound bites around
diplomacy that's a bumper sticker but
we're not going to let you have it this
woman is some extraordinary guest
Ambassador Samantha power thank you so
much for joining us today